i'm so happy for you and your beautiful
baby and this is the first time you've
been away from your baby yeah this is
the first time i've been away from her
and she started school this week which
has been which she's been sending me the
cutest
little videos and i feel
so so there she is oh my gosh
babies and doggies
oh there's river he's he's been with me
for 13 years
many stages of my life and then that's
our new little puppy early or we live in
england early
that's early oh
so happy for your life
i think we have also one other thing in
common that i found out about which is
our obsession with caffeine and your you
have a favorite coffee right yes irving
farm i'm obsessed with irving which
i try to stay at a hotel that's close
enough to irving farms so that i can
go like get out of bed in my pajamas and
go over to irving farm
and get a coffee before i see anybody
well we wanted to play a little game
with you if you don't mind oh sure yeah
okay great um we wanted to put your
taste buds to the test
i haven't had enough coffee
thank you
thank you so much
[Applause]
alrighty good
um
one of them is is irving my favorite oh
if you can answer correctly no pressure
i wanted to give everyone in the
audience um a beautiful coffee maker
that i made
[Applause]
feels like haley and i do which is and i
heard it's like your last thought before
you go to bed yeah i go to bed i can't
wait to wake up in the morning because
all like i'm like
oh coffee
that's how i am with the tea i love this
so we wanted
share in this moment with you guys
um so will you kindly do a taste test
okay so i'm nervous this is a lot of
pressure because those are very
beautiful i know i'm sorry
my dad my my family drinks folgers
um that's interesting so one of these
are folgers
that's weird and i think that one might
have been folgers actually i think that
might have been what the senses were
that was folgers
[Applause]
okay i think it's this one
oh my god haley you're absolutely
[Applause]
uh okay let me let me try it again
i am so impressed
i don't know is it like uh starbucks
[Applause]
yes
and you get to have dream very first
coffee maker i made those coffee makers
with my heart and my mind and and
they're all um this advanced technology
so you will not see the screen display
until you touch it and then when you do
it will come on and you can make
yourself a beautiful pot of coffee and
join haley and i in saying cheers to
one's morning
and having a beautiful day and joining
us
my dear friend haley bennett ladies and
gentlemen cyrano is in theaters starting
tomorrow february 25th
and we'll be right back
[Music]